what's up good humans but uh we have
some new merch for you guys the store
closes tomorrow so check the link in the
description box below and in the
meanwhile enjoy this episode of look at
my eyes real quick
are you gay no look at my eyes real
quick are you gay no we brought together
seven straight men I am a straight man
I'm straight I am a straight man I'm
straight I am a straight man I'm
straight I'm a straight man one is a
liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize if the liar
survives he or she wins the entire prize
[Music]
raise your hand if you have if you've
had a girlfriend are you sexually
attracted to men no but I can appreciate
a good man okay that makes sense
you're you have a wedding ring I do when
did you get married eight years ago
eight years ago okay all right all right
what's right name Stephanie Wow do you
guys believe that right off the bat
Jonathan kind of went after me because I
had a wedding ring Oh guys who here's
kissed a dude or been kissed by dude
I've been kissed by a dude I've kissed
the dude yes I think that's why I dude
who here has it's to do didn't liked it
some wrong kiss him too dude I actually
kissed my best friend of my birthday one
of my best friends it was an accident
was yeah it was really funny my
girlfriend is there she saw glad we got
a lot of accomplished here yeah so clear
now okay so who knows who won the Super
Bowl was it does that matter what I
don't want to go I didn't think he was
the more but when it came down to it I
was like I got a play for strategy I got
a win
Oh only person you asked a question
that's what happens in all of these
episodes is the only person they ask
good question - is the one that gets
voted out has anyone here been mistaken
for a gay person yes why do you think
for me it's my voice and they're like
you're gay and I'm like I mean it might
be I don't know I think was like a
California accent I guess may I say like
a lot I get it was taken for being gay
all the time which is why I don't think
like it's you could tell by someone yeah
tell through their stories maybe how
could you identify a person by their
physical appearance whether they're gay
or not I don't think that's possible and
that's the conversation I tried to start
which was shut down pretty quickly I
feel like for this to be effective we
have to put everyone kind of in the spot
and like and then everyone else's
analyzes them ask me questions wait wait
look at my eyes real quick
are you gay no look at my eyes real
quick are you gay no because it can't
just be like Oh everyone gangs up on one
person cuz like then the gay person has
a chance like hide in the shadows or
hide in the noise you know what I mean
okay it was if they're gay they're gonna
act different very like you know 1960s
like mindset and that was just funny and
I was like I don't think we're gonna get
anything out of this have you ever seen
a penis I've seen multiple penises how
did you feel about them
I wasn't sexually attracted to any of
them but like here's the thing sometimes
things sometimes sometimes you see a
bunch because their locker room okay
he's trying to divert the situation in
my head I thought okay he's he's gotta
be the mole Wesley do you have a
girlfriend right now
I do not how do you meet and date now
I'm kind of like just committing to like
season of singleness you know okay nice
good job good job
see I respect that when was your first
girlfriend my first one was probably
like in college yeah it was it wasn't
very long though see my thing is I
should probably a cup I'm like Muslim so
my thing is like it's just dating is
just usually very
unconventional it's like very like
limited so I mean is that a thing in
Muslim culture to be taken I feel like
as far as like religion goes I mean
usually is another thing where it's like
okay you are really pretty devout I
would say yeah okay like I grew up like
going the mosque everything it's a very
like Don't Ask Don't Tell it's something
that needs to be addressed there should
be a lot of love coming out just in
general you know it shouldn't be
something where you know people get
ostracized for doing what they do and
being who they are
how's your relationship with your dad
it's fine Corey baseball of them I'm
trying to be challenging here I'm not
actually a jerk guys last person
open-book uh give it to me Josh did you
shave your butt oh yeah oh I don't I
don't don't
I don't okay unfortunately sorry have
you ever had a threesome I have not I
like I don't I don't understand it like
I got to focus on one person and who
usually who's that one person a man or a
female a girl yeah okay have you kissed
a dude he said he did I I have what was
what was the situation what you want to
say no I don't want to say no I'm gonna
be honest I've kissed the guy because I
was like that could be bye and then
turns out I wasn't what would that make
you a mold you're not making them all
because of or like a spectrum it's in
Kersey spectrum but it has to be caustic
they Jake are they gay currently or were
gay
[Music]
see you later Jason see your brother
where you would like to continue the
game I think based on just the whole
interaction whatever I think that no I
know calling out is so like bad and I
apologize but it's a game it's a game
you just say I think you're gay right
and so this is what I think this is
there's a lot of dominating the
conversation the body language and
trying to control everything I thought
he was acting maybe too macho okay maybe
he is over playing this straight role
I'm going to look at Wesley look at the
tattoo on his right arm right those are
three stakes what does that represent
the crucifixion all right I don't
necessarily believe he's gay Christians
that's my hunch I say it's more likely
that he is not then he is so wouldn't
make sense to take him out I'm voting
Wes that's that's what I'm know it
really sucks about this guy's is we
became friends and now I feel like we're
not so after this is over can we still
get beers yes I want to get it's a date
then after it have you wants you the one
thing I'll say I'm sure if you guys vote
me off all right let's do that thing how
many times has your gaydar been right in
real life I don't believe in that kind
of a thing so tell my brother he's he's
gay and I didn't know until he came out
and I was like woah what that I was like
shocked and so yeah the like K
stereotypes doesn't really match up but
did it ever like crossed your mind or
anything like did you ever even think
about it no I did a lot because a lot of
the times like what you're not paying
attention to right it's like it's easy
to miss you know what I mean right I
just I thought dude I guess so so
disqualifying yourself I was like I
guess having like a does not having a
gaydar but like not believing it I feel
like that still isn't like an accurate
statement I think we spent the first
four minutes just discussing how we were
gonna approach finding out who's gay and
like
we need to do the dang thing what's the
gayest thing about you all
honestly growing up me and my friends
literally just like poked our fingers up
each other's buds I'm Korean and there's
this thing called thumb team where it's
like horseplay or whatever to like come
up behind one of your friends and like
stick your like finger up their butt
like this and yell like dog team bro
why'd you move over there I thought it's
funny but I was with him in it like okay
I hear you I don't think you're it
what's the gayest thing that you I went
to school for a theater there you go not
gay oh no probably that I love people a
whole lot and it's like all I care about
pretty friendly is that considered gay
because that's gay happiness like people
might be like yo that dudes a little too
happy Mike yeah I am that's a good thing
I think the gayest thing that I do is I
love giving massages disease to anybody
I do the same and then sometimes when
I'm massaging a dude everyone's like oh
my god are you gay
and I'm like doesn't matter but how do
about how does that situation come
across are you like hey can i massage
you it's all consent it's all consent no
so do my friends my friends and then
we're like y'all let's massage that's
still the same thing about like what you
guys the best boy you're doing like cuz
you're calling it or not if you do gay
stuff like you're cool you're probably
not gay the gay thing about me honestly
would probably be like my just like
taste in music you know I'm like a
Beyonce fan I've been listening like
Britney Spears since like day one like
that's the kinda stuff I'm just really
into like pop music and that's that's my
thing I guess is it wait is it cool if I
do ask you ya know homosexuality I'm
like the like the Muslim community yeah
that's fine I feel like a lot of
religious organizations kind of take
that conservative approach where they're
like okay you know just everybody's
allowed in the religion but you know you
can't really so if you were would you be
comfortable like coming out would I be
yeah probably not just I'm being honest
for myself and just because I know how
Muslims are like I probably
[Music]
even when he was asked a question he
didn't really talk much
he gave like a really quick answer and
was like on to the next person I don't
like this game anymore can I go home
[Music]
sorry dude I thought Wes was definitely
the gay guy that's what I thought I
wanted to split the money with Evan but
if everyone else is being greedy or soy
ha ha then I guess I got to be greedy
with everybody else I've kind of treated
this round like a safety round where I
feel like I feel like we got rid of mole
but I feel like just see here just like
but one person out I don't think we did
again I'm putting myself out there again
like I'm probably like I still think
that Wes is the mole this is what I
think now we can take the money and we
can split it three ways I feel like
you're a very credible person I'm like
honestly I believe you but like to be
safe okay that works this is what I'm
thinking alright because saying I'm
Muslim is like the ultimate trump card
of saying like yeah I know I get that I
totally get that
so in this game anyone could be a liar
and I was like that is such a strong
play to use it's either absolute truth
or it's absolutely a lie because he
throughout the Muslim car I want to be
conscious so therefore he's trying to
play it up and then therefore he is gays
what you're saying
well like whether or not he is I feel
like that's you that's like kind of so
this a notice to vote where was that is
this the immigration episode no I was
born in Pakistan after I called that out
I was like dang maybe this wasn't like
the best like tactic he was super mature
and super like understanding and like
understood the context of the game the
socks dude hey hey we're homies here
come on we're all just be honest like
really good shoes man can be gay dude
just kidding sorry I mean that's true
Jonathan I love you but if you are the
mole for what I do outside of these
doors play I'm not the mole
I'm just so disheartened right now yeah
there you go to be honest I was
surprised I made it as far as I did in
the game I feel like I played that hand
really strong it was just like you know
what all Muslim it can't be me we talked
about the second come on continue the
game to do it continue the game Jared
continue the game continue the game I
dude dude I want the money because I'm
competitive but I think the moles out no
this is this is called trust this is
where it happens we won I am so confused
hey who's the mole wait dude I was
shocked I thought it was Western
Kentucky time I am happy that I made it
as far as I made it see there were some
that got it right away
and there are some like Wes had no idea
there was never a point where I thought
Evan was them all I hope that people
take away the fact that people are more
than just their sexuality I think that's
the root of everything
any defining identity of the person we
we can't judge so quickly I was shocked
I mean this breaks my entire you know
mind when it comes to stereotypes and
everything oh can I have mention one
thing because of the whole situation I'm
taking the money and I'm donating it to
Trevor Project yeah that's what I'm
gonna do so sweet is that why you wore
those shoes oh hello mom
yeah we want one were you guys I thought
you were doing with the longest time
hello good humans go to our website to
purchase some what merch purchase and
some work yes
yeah yeah okay bye bye